[Music]
is there a tour movie in the works when
you guys hit the road that would be and
I was like if anybody wants to reach out
to us first
I manage enough its harmony talking
possible tour movie plans with et
Heather new album out Friday signifies a
rebirth for the band and why their
friendship is stronger than ever and I
feel like we almost got we've got our
power back and we learned to love music
again and we know that in 10 years it'll
mean what it means now to us you know
it's still special and it's something
that will forever be proud of does it
signify a rebirth a fifth harmony or a
continuation a rebirth everything every
birth and continuation at the same time
but definitely every birth and the the
really amazing thing is that we have
such an incredible bond with the
floorless and
I like so it's really such a special
experience it can't really describe it
we've discovered so much and has
experienced so much especially at this
age we're all in our 20s now boom we're
super super proud of this era that we
who we are individually it's just
amazing for me especially to see
everybody growing into you know a woman
mm-hmm and even for myself I've
discovered who I am as a person as a
woman as a daughter so that itself I'm
excited for what for everyone to see
yeah that and believest you guys seem
stronger and closer than ever what is
the secret to the friendship you know
you feel heard amongst because
especially when you're working with a
group dynamic with four women it's it's
hard because there's so many little
things all the time that are going on
that you can get caught up in but then
when we talk about things and we sit
down with each other and we really
communicate with each other that's when
we gather some of our strongest moments
of our really noble moments with each
other and then we grow from say like you
know this isn't back of my mind but the
same time it's a part of growth you have
to like break that barrier for yourself
[Music]